got a lot of work to do over here to
save the West there was a book on this
topic
that book is called
how to save the West It Is by a friend
of mine Spencer Clavin absolutely no
relation to Andrew Clavin I am actually
writing a review of this book for the
Claremont Review of Books and when you
write a book review
you you go through a book and you
usually summarize the plot you give your
take on the information presented the
way in which it's presented the style of
the book The prose all of that and then
you list the things that the author
could have done better and I've I've
written plenty of book reviews and I
usually find all sorts of problems with
books and I'm I'm not exaggerating I
I did not have a criticism of this book
I was actually thinking do I need to
just make up a criticism just so my book
review doesn't look too positive that is
how good it is we're joined Now by my
friend Spencer Flavin Mr Clavin welcome
to the show
Michael my ears were burning hearing you
uh talk about that I was disappointed
that the review wasn't going to have
like you know the author's ears are too
big or something in there because I just
think that would be good well I was
thinking as a little addendum to the
review to say you know look my praise of
the book notwithstanding the author is a
big fat dumb stupid idiot but but I
don't know I ran out of words by the end
so it is I hate to say it you know it's
men and especially buddies especially
long time buddies it's it feels very
strange to just give a sincere
compliment it feels that's not how men
talk to one another but it's very
squishy and weird yeah it is squishy and
weird and I feel like a big lib uh it's
just so good and I I actually I went
into the book
thinking okay I now I see a little way
that I could criticize it because the
book opens up and it's talking about
things that are really present they're
very urgent kind of modern things that
you would see in the headlines and I
said okay this is going to be one of
these just okay Spencer's going to cover
the news and then just very quickly you
tie the the things that we're seeing
around us right now into
polybius and Plato and Aristotle and
then you come right back up to Kendrick
Lamar and then you come to and it's and
it's so seamless and it's so you
actually finish the book and you say oh
this guy is not just showing off his
scholarship and oh this guy is not just
riffing on the news this guy has an
Urgent Message for what to do about a
civilization that that feels as though
it's not only in Ruins but but still has
some pieces of the marble about to fall
down on our heads
you know it's really perceptive and
thanks for saying that this is a book
that is based on the radical idea that
the past has something to say to the
present and that's basically it that's
the simple claim which is not so simple
anymore since as you were just talking
about earlier in the show the the very
idea of Western Civilization that we
might be inheritors of a tradition
carriers of a flame that comes down from
these kind of two uh Central
civilizations Athens and Jerusalem this
whole notion is portray Aid regularly in
the news as somehow primitive it's
superstitious it's maybe kind of
racially chauvinist people make all
sorts of accusations you're a racist
you're a sexist for talking about those
dumb old guys and one of the things that
I try to do in this book is just say
look you know every day we wake up we
see some news story that makes us feel
like everything's falling apart and it's
really easy to think that all of this is
just the result of you know rapidly
accelerating technology and science has
transformed the world and of course
those things may be true but what the
book is about is a lot of the questions
that were coming up against are actually
extremely fundamental they've been with
Humanity basically ever since we were on
this planet and there are some really
rich uh answers to these questions that
are available from the tradition if
you'll just look and you know they do
everything they can to try and convince
you not to do that they tell you that
these books are outdated that they're
bad that they're evil that Aristotle was
some kind of you know you the chauvinist
racist whatever
um all to prevent you from understanding
that the answers to questions like why
am I here what's my place in the
universe what's a human being um these
questions that we're grappling with now
you will find better sane or clearer
more Humane answers in some of these
texts that the book deals with than you
will from like Dr fauci and whatever
modern you know un Guru is supposed to
be in charge of us today so that's
exactly the point of the book it's just
as you said you know I've got about 30
seconds left in the main portion of the
show for the hoi polloi out there who
have not yet gone over to dailywire.com
Knowles use code Knowles And subscribe
you you say in the subtitle it's ancient
wisdom for five modern crises
what are the modern crises
I'll list them off and then I'll say a
little bit about them the first is the
crisis of reality is anything true or
false the second is the crisis of the
body to our unique human forms have
anything to say about us or should they
just be replaced re-engineered uh
transformed with gender surgery
um the third is the crisis of meaning
can we really believe that anything has
any meaning Beyond just the mere fact of
evolution and and replication and this
leads directly into the deepest crisis
which I think is the crisis of religion
can we believe in a Creator God that has
an interest in us that's the most
important question before us and I
answer it in the affirmative yes we can
before turning to the crisis of the
regime which is the most immediate one
what's going on in America what's going
to happen to us and can we survive I
want you to give us I want you to give
us the answers to that but I don't want
you to give it to the Hoy polloi these
freeloaders who they show up I
appreciate that they show up but they
don't want to Fork over
their hard-earned money because I don't
know they want to go buy eggs or
something like that which is impossible
and you never you're never going to
afford eggs these days
[Music]
foreign